a particle moves in the XY plane so that
at any time T is greater than or equal
to zero its position vector is and they
give us the X component and the y
component of our position vectors and
they're both functions of time what is
the particles acceleration vector at
time T equals three all right so our
position let's denote that it's a vector
valued function it's going to be a
function of time it is a vector and they
already told us that the X component of
our position is negative 3 T to the
third power plus 4 T squared and the y
component is T to the third power plus 2
and so you give me any time greater than
or equal to zero I put it in here and I
can give you the corresponding x and y
components and this is one form of
notation for a vector another way of
writing this you might be familiar with
engineering notation it might be written
like or sometimes people write this as
unit vector notation negative 3 to the
third plus 4t squared times the unit
vector in the horizontal direction plus
T to the third plus 2 times the unit
vector in the vertical direction this is
just a noting the same thing this is the
X component this is the Y component this
is a component in the horizontal
direction this is a component in the
vertical direction of the Y component
now the key realization is if you have
the position vector well the velocity
vector is just going to be the
derivative of that so so V of T is just
going to be equal to R prime of T which
is going to be equal to well you just
have to take the corresponding
derivatives of each of the components so
let's do that so if we want to take the
derivative of the X component here with
respect to time we're gonna use the
power rule a bunch so it's 3 times
negative 3 so it's negative 9t squared
and then plus 2 times 4 is 8
so plus 8 T to the first so plus 8 T and
then and then over here for the Y
component so the derivative of T to the
third with respect to T is 3 T squared 3
T's
and the derivative of two is just a zero
so actually have space to write the
three T squared even bigger 3t squared
all right and if we want to find the
acceleration function as a or the the
vector valued function that gives us
acceleration as a function of time well
that's just going to be the derivative
of the velocity function with respect to
time so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to let me give
myself some space and so the x component
well I just take the derivative of the X
component again and let me find a color
I haven't used yet I'll use this green
so let's see 2 times negative 9 negative
18 times T to the first power plus 8
derivative of a T is just 8 if we're
taking the derivative with respect to T
and then and then here in the orange
derivative 3t squared so it's 2 power
rule here over and over again 2 times 3
is 6 t to the first power just 60 so
this is we've just been able to by
taking the derivative of a vector value
of this position vector valued function
twice I'm able to find the acceleration
function and now I just have to evaluate
it at T equals 3 so our acceleration at
T is equal to 3 is equal to so in green
it's going to be negative 18 times 3
plus 8 comma comma and then we're gonna
have 6 times 3 6 times 3 and so what
does this simplify to
well this is going to be equal to let's
see negative 18 times 3 is negative 54
negative 54 plus 8 is negative 46
negative 46 and 6 times 3 is 18 did I do
that arithmetic right so this is
negative 54 Plus 8 so negative 54 plus 4
would be negative 50 plus another 4
would be negative 46 yep there you have
it
negative 46 comma comma 18 that is its
acceleration that is his acceleration
vector at T is equal to three